I am paget Brewster and today we are
going to talk about the Kellogg brothers
in 1876 dr. John Kellogg created a
sanitarium in Battle Creek Michigan
except he was an orator in the
seventh-day Adventist Church he tells
his patients no sex no meat no alcohol
no sugar no anything print or sensual
aren't you guys tired okay all right he
tells his patients you need to take at
least two solid ropey poops per day in
1880 dr. John reaches out to his younger
brother will who he beat up the whole
time he was growing up but he says hey
um leave that broom company I got this
you know sanitarium
spa thing there's over a thousand people
a week here hanging out swimming and
doing stuff you should just come and you
know help me out with everything and
will says okay I gotta get out of here
we'll it's just sort of this sad little
whipping boy for his big famous brother
John
he actually said I use my brother as a
foot warmer in the winter I don't even
know what that means like he beat him up
and he stuck his feet under him for the
anyway he has to shave him he actually
has to call his own brother dr. Kellogg
and has to run the kitchen and has to
run the books so dr. John tells his
younger brother will hey make something
that people want to eat because no one
wants vegetarian food so you do this cuz
I'm busy
I got a you know do lectures and stuff
so we'll who's bookie bookkeeping office
office is next to the kitchen one night
he's trying to make this stupid
vegetarian he leaves the dough out he
comes in the next morning and the dough
that he left out has molded and he's
like a god damn it his moldy I'm on a
budget and he puts it through the
grinder anyway and a small amount of
mold made that dough flakes cornflakes
and he's like hole oh oh we may I made a
cereal so he tells John John comes down
ha you know and then they start
producing this cereal cornflakes like
cornflakes that we all know that we'll
discover with mold one week CW Post this
industrialist is visiting and John says
oh you should see the corn flakes for me
you were making our own cereal and will
is saying oh no don't I made I made that
don't you say and
oh I'm not talking right all together
but close enough CW Post steals it sells
it makes a million dollars so Will's
like you man you me you does if we add
sugar we can sell the cereal and John
says you can't put sugar on it
that's not seventh-day Adventist who do
you think you are will says oh you know
you know who I think I am I think I'm
the guy who invented in cornflakes I'm
gonna put sugar on him and sell him and
be you so he takes his cereal and he
sets up the Kellogg toasted flakes
company will makes it a million dollar
enterprise
he's like I'm putting sugar on my bu
the younger brother now finally comes
out of his older brother's shadow and
becomes a huge American industrialist
the brothers sue each other back and
forth for 10 years I want the name of
Kellogg's I want the name of Kellogg's I
want the name of Kellogg's no I deserve
it I made the whatever so will this
younger brother wins the name in federal
court I'm gonna burp it's okay I hope
it's just a burp
will is a huge industrialist in the
United States he invents a bunch of
cereals meanwhile John loses all
credibility in 1943 John is on his
deathbed he writes to his younger
brother having not spoken for the past
20 years
and he gave it to his social secretary
or whatever he had no family his only
feeling was will she never sent it but
will eight years later also dying blind
was told on his deathbed your brother
wrote a letter eight years ago saying
I'm sorry I screwed up I apologize I
treated you as a lesser man when in fact
I was the lesser man essentially that's
what he said I read it but I can't
remember entirely but that's essentially
what he said sorry will sat up on his
deathbed and said good god why didn't
anyone tell me about this before now and
he died
that's just awful that's the worst and
yeah but right but will was right and
you want to put them resume on him yeah
there's like nobody's just mold mold
flakes
you